PEGI 12
chasing the arch heretic and his
planet-killer towards the eye of terror
is the greatest test I have ever faced
but my soul is armored in faith the
Imperial Creed guides me banishing all
doubt or regret the Emperor
stands with us and I have felt the
purity of his righteousness I have
witnessed his glory burn away to
darkness I have seen the Imperials
indomitable ferocity unleashed upon its
countless enemies
I saw courage and honor displayed in the
Emperor's name I saw the unwavering
loyalty and righteousness that he
inspired no fortress could withstand the
Emperor's Rock no fury could overcome
his protection
the Emperor's light cleanses even the
darkest corruption thunders even the
strongest curse
his glory brings salvation to those who
embrace his ideals even the Fallen are
offered a chance of redemption in the
Empress service through death sacrifice
duty honor these hour the emperor
requires of us we have located so that
admiral spire he is gravely injured said
the sanguinary priest
we cannot allow Abaddon to escape let
our enemies tremble for the angels of
death have come to join the hunt we
shall know no fear
you